Dans le Sud-Kivu,
au cœur de l'ancien Zaïre.
Depuis toujours, on chante
et on danse les gorilles.
Je suis né ici,
depuis mon enfance,
j'aimais la forêt et les animaux.
Pour l'instant, ces chants et ces danses
veulent encore dire quelque chose.
Pour l'instant, il y a encore
quelques gorilles vivants.
À 6h30 chaque matin,
Bob Moulinbee se rend à son travail.
Il n'y a plus de véhicule pour les civils.
Tout a été réquisitionné par les militaires.
Moi, je suis de garde.
Mon devoir primordial,
est de protéger les gorilles.
Montagnes, volcans, gorilles,
donnez-nous votre force !
Nous vous en supplions...
1000 mètres d'ascension en 1 h 30 de course
pour atteindre la base du parc Kahuzi-Biega.
Le parc est classé patrimoine
mondial de l'humanité.
Dans ces forêts vivent
les derniers gorilles.
Au programme Ce matin, une séance
de rééducation pour 40 braconniers,
qui sortent de prison.
Ce sont eux qui ont massacré les animaux
dont ils portent les crânes.
Des centaines de bêtes tuées à cause
de la guerre, à cause de la misère.
Les éléphants de la région
ont été exterminés en cinq ans.
Objectif des responsables du parc :
transformer ces braconniers,
en protecteurs des derniers gorilles.
À cause de la guerre,
tous les animaux sont morts ou tués,
ça me fait mal au cœur.
Tous en ligne !
Le chef les a pris en charge,
ça m'enchante beaucoup et j'espère,
que ce braconnage ne s'effectuera
plus dans le parc,
puisque ce sont ces gens là
qui faisaient ça.
- Bonjour.
- Bonjour, chef.
Vous avez accepté de travailler
comme pisteurs pour le parc.
Vous avez abandonné le braconnage
pour surveiller les gorilles.
Oui, chef.
Regardez bien ça.
C'est un crâne de gorille.
On l'a retrouvé mort dans le parc.
Un gorille comme celui-ci,
quand un touriste vient
le voir à Kahuzi-Biega,
Il paie 120 dollars,
pour le voir une seule fois.
Un kilo de viande de gorille,
ça coûte combien ?
Dans les 200 000 nouveaux zaïres.
200 000 nouveaux zaïres !
- Ça fait un quart de dollar, non ?
- Oui.
Et si tu vends
toute la carcasse du gorille,
Est-ce que ça te rapporte 120 dollars ?
Non.
Même pas 50 dollars.
En plus, une fois tué, le gorille
ne rapporte plus rien. C'est fini.
Musho, viens ici.
Regardez Musho, il travaille
maintenant pour le parc.
Il est garde.
Et avec le peu qu'il reçoit,
il a aujourd'hui des bottes,
un pantalon et une chemise.
Vous voyez ?
Toi, viens te mettre à côté de Musho.
Vous voyez la différence ?
Ici, un garde, là, un braconnier.
Qu'est-ce qui est mieux ? La vie
de garde ou celle de braconnier ?
La vie de garde !
Dans les forêts du parc vivent
des milliers de personnes,
celles qui ont fui la guerre et ces massacres,
mais aussi les massacreurs,
des bandes armées, les tueurs
responsables du génocide rwandais.
Pour protéger les derniers gorilles,
Bob et ses gardes,
ont une petite escorte de militaires.
Sur cette route, le mois dernier,
deux véhicules ont été attaqués,
par ceux que l'on appelle ici,
les inciviques.
On estime que 10 000 d'entre eux
se cachent dans cette réserve naturelle.
Ils sont en train d'exterminer
les derniers gorilles pour survivre.
Dans cette jungle truffée de fusils
et de ventres affamés,
une vie ne pèse pas grand chose.
D'autres gardes sont partis devant
pour tenter de repérer les traces,
d'une famille de gorilles qu'ils suivent
depuis quelques jours.
Ils savent à peu près
où ils doivent se retrouver.
Les autres sont à trois kilomètres de là.
Plus d'une heure de marche dans la forêt dense.
1 h pendant laquelle
il faut être aux aguets.
- Tu as laissé une balle ?
- Non !
- Il était chargé.
- C'est pas moi !
Que se passe-t-il ?
N'ayez pas peur,
ce sont les militaires qui ont
un peu bougé leurs armes.
Celui qui doit les conduire, c'est Kalolo,
un pygmée, un homme de la forêt.
Sans lui, sortis des chemins,
ils seraient perdu.
Aujourd'hui, nous sommes
avec les militaires,
car nous n'avons pas les moyens
de nous protéger en brousse.
C'est pour cela que nous les appelons
pour nous aider à patrouiller.
On est encore en pleine guerre,
il ne faut pas le cacher...
Vous voyez comment nos gorilles ont péri.
Il y avait des hommes armés dans la forêt,
qui tuaient les gorilles avec des armes.
La trace que Kalolo a choisi
est peut-être un passage de gorille,
mais peut-être aussi
la piste d'une bande armée.
Nous reconnaissons les traces,
d'abord, nous regardons ici.
Il n'y a pas de tache ici.
C'est encore propre.
C'est comme ça que
nous remarquons les traces.
Ils étaient ici hier soir pour le repas.
Normalement, en 1 h de marche, nous
aurions dû rejoindre l'autre patrouille.
Mais voilà, cela fait 2 h
que notre colonne avance.
Où êtes-vous ? On tourne en rond.
Où êtes-vous ?
On est déjà à la troisième colline.
Vous nous entendez ?
Vous n'êtes pas loin,
c'est la colline d'après, continuez.
On vient à votre rencontre.
À force de tourner en rond,
ils ne savent plus où ils sont.
Pour la direction à suivre,
les avis divergent.
Seul Kalolo, le Pygmée,
semble sûr de lui.
Même ici, dans les environs,
les inciviques passent.
Si nous allons en brousse,
c'est une façon,
de nous donner puisque
nous avons l'amour du travail.
Mais je ne vous dis pas qu'il est une
partie du parc qui est vraiment épargnée.
Kalolo avait vu juste,
l'autre patrouille est bien là.
Les gorilles ne sont pas loin.
- Ils sont là.
- Là-bas ?
- Toute la famille ?
- Ils sont tous là.
- On avance ?
- En se baissant.
- On y va doucement ?
- Oui.
Quand vous les suivez, il ne faut
pas y aller d'une façon brutale,
là, il ne va pas vous recevoir.
Il faut d'abord y aller doucement.
Il faut être tranquille.
Il faut que vous soyez poli.
C'est comme si vous allez chez un ami.
Voici le Gorilla Gorilla graueri,
une des trois espèces,
la plus impressionnante de toutes.
200 kilos pour 1m80.
On le trouve uniquement à l'Est du Zaïre.
Lui, s'appelle Muga Huka.
C'est le fils aîné d'une famille
qui a failli être exterminé.
Au départ, avant même la guerre,
c'est une famille que l'on suivait.
Il y a un an, Bob était dans la forêt
à la recherche de cette famille,
mais il n'a rien pu faire.
Après, a un moment,
les hommes armés
sont venus dans la forêt,
quand je faisais la localisation,
j'ai entendu des tires,
C'est ainsi que la famille a diminué.
Ils étaient 19 et il n'en reste que 4.
Parmi les quinze morts, Mucha Beret,
le vieux chef de famille.
Muga Huka, était trop jeune
pour prendre sa suite.
Alors c'est la première femelle
qui assurait l'intérim, la régence.
Une femelle qui dirige le clan,
on n'avait jamais vu ça.
Au bout d'un an,
Muga Huka a pris de l'assurance,
il prend la place de sa mère.
Bob l'a constaté,
depuis quelques semaines, c'est Muga Huka
qui se met entre la famille et les hommes.
Il commence à se montrer
à la place de la femelle.
Il a déjà pris le pouvoir,
Il commence à se montrer
et à défendre la famille.
Venez le voir quand il se repose,
il sieste comme l'homme.
Les petits jouent comme nos enfants,
Ce sont des animaux
mais ils ont quand même une vie,
qui est comme celle de l'homme.
Si les gens tuent ces animaux,
c'est très regrettable.
Chaque fois, je viens en forêt,
je veux voir les gorilles,
là, je serai très content.
Une fois qu'ils ont localisé une famille,
Bob et ses hommes passent plusieurs
heures à côté des gorilles.
Cela se sait dans la forêt,
il faut que cela se sache.
Il faut que les braconniers sachent que
les gorilles ont leur garde du corps.
Avant la guerre,
les gardes en avaient compté 285.
Ils n'en ont retrouvé que 99.
Ils ont même perdu
le plus célèbre, Maheshe,
un vieux mal.
La photo de ce gorille,
c'est le gorille Maheshe.
C'est le plus célèbre gorille
que nous avions.
Tout le monde voulait le voir.
Tu peux lui demander qui l'a tué ?
Raconte-nous ce que tu as fait.
Dis-nous qui a tué Maheshe.
Ce n'est pas moi qui l'ai tué.
Impossible de savoir qui l'a fait.
En général,
les braconniers travaillent seuls.
Quand ils se rencontrent,
ils se tirent dessus.
En plus, les gorilles,
ressemblent trop à l'homme.
Nous autres pygmées,
on ne peut pas les manger.
C'est comme si on mangeait de l'homme.
Mais tous les pygmées
ne respectent plus le tabou.
Lors de la création du parc,
les petits hommes de la forêt,
en ont été chassés et ils ont été
refoulés jusqu'à sa lisière.
Leurs villages sont régulièrement
pillés par des bandes armées.
Les pygmées sont les plus
pauvres des pauvres.
Ils ont découvert la civilisation
et en même temps la famine.
Leur village, c'est ****,
Bob y est venu pour rencontrer
leur chef, Maeshe Beret junior,
le fils du dernier
roi pygmée de la forêt.
Aujourd'hui, les pygmées retournent
dans la forêt et pour manger,
eux aussi, tu les gorilles.
Pour la palabre, Maeshe Beret
a quitté sa casquette,
et remis sa toque de roi.
Tu sais que beaucoup de tes frères
ont trouvé du travail.
Avant, on en embauchait un ou deux,
maintenant, on les embauche par dizaines,
et on en embauchera d'autres.
C'est pour ça, chef,
qu'on voulait te demander,
si on pouvait empêcher
les tiens de tuer nos animaux.
Nous autres Pygmées,
nous sommes contents de voir
que vous donnez à nos braconniers,
un vrai travail.
Je suis sûr qu'ils feront de leur mieux.
Pour protéger les gorilles.
Ici, chez nous.
Plus aucun Pygmée ne quitte
le village pour braconner.
Le seul problème,
c'est le manque de travail.
On attend les autres embauches
avec impatience.
Le braconnage, on n'en veut plus.
En fait, Bob était porteur
de bonnes nouvelles.
Tout braconnier qui acceptera
d'arrêter sera embauché par le parc,
embauché et payé. Le salaire :
huit verres de haricots,
six verres de riz et un demi-litre
d'huile par semaine,
et six francs en fin de mois
pour le savon et le sel.
À une demi heure de marche
du village pygmée, la route.
Kavumu, où Bob a sa maison.
Il s'y est installé il y a un an.
Il fuyait les combats.
Sa maison avait été rasée.
Avant la guerre,
Bob touchait 600 francs par mois.
Aujourd'hui, il n'a plus que 200 francs
pour nourrir sa famille.
Ce sont mes enfants.
Ma fille est là-bas et la grande
est à Bukavu pour les études,
Il y a les garçons, ici,
après les garçons,
il y a une fille là,
il y en a une autre ici,
après une autre ici...
Après celle-ci, il y a celle-ci,
après celle-ci, il y a celui-ci.
Et après, il y a celui-ci.
200 francs pour onze, pour Bob,
ses neuf enfants et sa femme.
Pendant la guerre,
j'ai perdu tous mes biens,
j'avais une grosse radio,
une télévision,
beaucoup d'habits, mes enfants
s'habillaient bien, ils mangeaient bien,
mais quand la guerre a éclaté,
j'ai tout laissé, je n'ai sauvé
que mon corps et mes enfants.
J'ai du tout reprendre à zéro.
Nous devons protéger notre nature,
protéger notre parc, corps et âme.
Ô Kitonda, toi, le gorille !
Ô Kitonda !
Et toi, Mikeno, le volcan,
protège-le...
L'Afrique des gorilles,
c'est l'Afrique des Grands Lacs,
avec cette guerre qui n'en finit pas.
Sur l'autre rive du lac Kivu, le Rwanda,
les Hutu et les Tutsis, le génocide.
1 million de morts, des centaines
de milliers de gens qui fuient,
et se réfugient ici, au Congo, au pied
des plus vieux volcans du monde,
le berceau de l'humanité.
Sur les pentes de ces volcans
vit une autre espèce,
la plus menacée,
les gorilles de montagne.
Ils ont été rendus célèbres
par cette femme, Dian Fossey,
une scientifique américaine.
Au début des années 70, elle fut la première
à les approcher et à les étudier,
la première à démontrer scientifiquement,
qu'ils sont nos plus proches cousins.
Elle a vécu quinze ans avec eux,
essayant de les défendre.
En août 1985, Dian Fossey
est assassinée par des braconniers.
Les gorilles perdent leur ange gardien.
C'est ici que son arrivée en 1994,
200 000 réfugiés rwandais.
Ils avaient construit le camp Kibumba au pied
des volcans, à la lisière du parc Virunga,
où habitaient les gorilles de Dian Fossey.
200 000 réfugiés qui sont restés 2 ans,
jusqu'à ce qu'il ne reste plus assez
de bois pour faire le feu,
plus assez d'animaux pour se nourrir.
Cela n'a tenu que deux ans.
Aujourd'hui, il ne reste
plus que des ruines,
la forêt détruite sur des dizaines
et des dizaines de kilomètres,
et beaucoup de fantômes.
Les gorilles et les hommes qui ont échappé à
l'hécatombe sont allés plus loin, plus haut,
vers le sommet des volcans,
pour les gorilles, le dernier sanctuaire.
Mais un homme a pris la suite
de Dian Fossey, Gapyra.
Il était âgé de quinze ans lorsqu'il a
rencontré la scientifique américaine.
Son premier gorille, Gapyra l'avait
vu alors qu'il n'avait que six ans.
Gapyra est le chef
des gardes du parc Virunga,
de ce qu'il reste du parc Virunga,
de ce qu'il reste aussi des gardes.
Je suis le fils d'un garde parc.
Si j'ai terminé l'université ou bien
les études, c'est grâce à ce parc.
Alors, moi aussi, je me suis engagé.
Depuis deux ans, ils n'ont pas touché
de salaire et 80 d'entre eux,
ont été tués en cinq ans.
Soyons patients.
Nos dirigeants connaissent nos problèmes.
Je suis sûr qu'ils font
tout leur possible,
pour améliorer nos conditions de vie.
Je vous demande donc,
de continuer à croire en votre travail.
La dernière fois que l'on a vu des Européens
dans la région, c'était le 14 août 1998.
Six touristes venus à bord de deux
véhicules pour monter voir les gorilles.
Mais il y avait
une bande de miliciens hutus,
les chauffeurs restés
dans les 4x4 sont assassinés,
les voitures sont pillées puis brûlées.
Au retour de la forêt, ils les ont
interceptés de l'autre côté,
après la sortie du parc,
ils les ont poursuivis,
ils en ont arrêté 4 parmi les 6,
deux sont parvenus à s'échapper.
Après sept jours, ils ont libéré
une dame pour qu'elle aille,
alerter la communauté internationale.
Nous n'avons pas de nouvelles
des autres touristes européens.
Aucune revendication,
aucun corps n'a été retrouvé.
Mais il reste peu de chance
de les revoir vivants.
Les miliciens et autres hommes en armes,
eux, sont toujours là.
Les Interahamwe, comme on
les nomme ici, là encore,
ont dit qu'ils seraient 10 000
mais qui les a comptés ?
Pour le moment, il y a un problème.
Les Interahamwe ont érigé les bivouacs,
dans les parcs,
alors nous avons des difficultés,
pour aller suivre
le mouvement des gorilles.
Et c'est ainsi que nous avons perdu,
certains gardes sont morts
l'année passée.
Et vraiment, c'était un danger.
80 gardes tués en cinq ans, tous tombés
lors de ses patrouilles en forêt,
tuées aussi bien par les braconniers
que par les miliciens.
La trace qu'il fait suivre à ses hommes
et celle d'un groupe de gorilles.
Gapyra en a la certitude.
Ils ont mangé les lianes.
Les éléphants préfèrent
ces lianes également.
Des éléphants,
il n'en reste pratiquement plus.
À peine cinq ou six,
ils ont été exterminés.
Qu'un militaire reste avec nous
et que les autres passent devant.
Allez-y, passez.
Il y a des indices ici ?
Regarde s'il y a des poils.
Quelques poils, ils sont gris.
Pour Gapyra un indice suffisant,
ce gorille, il le connaît.
C'est Kitonda.
Le gorille se lève tôt le matin,
alors vers 9 h,
il commence la première sieste.
Ils étaient ici ce matin vers 9 h.
Après la sieste, la famille
de Kitonda s'est remise en route,
à la recherche d'orchidées sauvages.
C'est la saison.
Ils ne sont plus très loin,
nous allons bientôt les rattraper,
alors, il faut prendre des précautions.
Quand on arrive devant le gorille,
on donne l'arme et on la cache.
C'est pour que les gorilles ne puissent
pas se familiariser aux armes.
Le braconnier peut arriver avec une
arme, il va croire que c'est un ami.
Ce raclement de gorge,
c'est du langage gorille.
Gapyra annonce sa venue,
ils le reconnaîtront.
Les gorilles l'utilisent entre eux,
ça veut dire "tout va bien".
Le premier contact est le plus difficile,
puisque à ce moment là,
il est agressif.
Quand vous les voyez, vous vous
mettez accroupis ou bien à genoux,
comme ça il voit que vous êtes petit
par rapport à lui.
Elle fuit devant nous.
Impossible de rester avec elle,
changement de stratégie.
On doit d'abord identifier le mâle à dos
argenté qui doit stabiliser la famille.
Le mâle dominant
a toujours le dos argenté.
Ses poils virent au gris
lorsqu'il devient adulte,
lorsqu'il est en âge de quitter ses
parents et de créer une famille.
Il arrive.
Kitonda.
C'est le chef de la famille.
C'était un passage d'intimidation.
Ça faisait beaucoup de jours
sans voir de visiteurs.
Il n'est pas agressif et c'est
la raison pour laquelle on l'a appelé,
en dialecte local Kitonda, qui signifie
qui est calme et pacifique.
C'est un juvénile qui va passer.
Dans cette famille, il y a des juvéniles,
en voilà un qui va rejoindre son papa.
Souvent ce sont des silverbacks,
qui font des tapes d'intimidations.
Souvent les jeunes aussi en jouent.
Ils font des tapes comme ça.
Quand il fait ça, c'est pour intimider,
pour dire à une famille voisine,
je suis là.
Elles s'évitent habituellement, bien qu'elle
soit localisée dans un même territoire,
dans un même domaine vital.
C'est un langage qui peut être
écouté à plus de deux kilomètres.
En se frappant la poitrine, Kitonda
nous à bien signifier,
que nous étions chez lui.
Mais à l'évidence, il nous accepte.
La famille est réunie. Ils sont dix.
Il y a Kitonda, ses quatre femelles,
trois jeunes enfants et deux bébés.
Une famille de rescapés.
Il s'appelle Kalevuro.
C'est parce qu'il se tape
toujours sur les lèvres.
Il rebrousse chemin
pour avertir les autres.
Ce jour-là, un agent du gouvernement
était venu avec Gapyra,
sa mission : voir si la région pouvait
être à nouveau ouverte aux visiteurs.
Si tu vois qu'il avance
vers toi pour te toucher,
il faut reculer de 7 mètres.
C'est ce que dit le règlement.
Et s'il s'avance vers nous ?
Il faut prendre des branches,
et les secouer devant lui.
On secoue doucement,
jusqu'à ce qu'il recule.
Les gorilles sont génétiquement
si proches de nous,
que nos maladies se transmettent
par simple contact.
Une grippe humaine peut en quelques
jours anéantir toute une famille.
- Il a les yeux rouges.
- Ils ont tous les yeux rouges.
Attention, il s'approche.
Est-ce que dans ces conditions,
on peut ouvrir le tourisme ?
Si les militaires sécurisent
l'habitat des gorilles,
et s'ils acceptent d'accompagner
les visiteurs comme on le fait,
de l'autre côté au Rwanda,
il y a moyen d'ouvrir le tourisme.
Les gardes ne peuvent pas assurer cette
sécurité sans la présence des militaires ?
Nos gardes ne sont pas armés.
Si nous avons des armes
et si nous pouvons nous même réussir,
à assurer la sécurité dans ce secteur.
Pour le moment, non.
Nous avons toujours besoin
de la présence des militaires.
Depuis le début de la guerre,
il y a quatre gorilles qui ont été tués.
Ce que je crains,
c'est qu'il arrivera un jour,
où le gorille sera pris dans les faits,
comme ce fut le cas,
il y a une perte de dix individus.
Sur le chemin du retour,
l'oeil de l'un des gardes,
est attiré par ces branchages foulés.
Ça c'est un piège que le garde
viennent de trouver.
Ils tendent ce piège
pour attraper les antilopes.
Alors maintenant,
il y a des jeunes gorilles,
qui se font attraper dans le piège.
Le collier s'enfonce
très sérieusement dans la chair.
Et si la plaie est infectée,
le gorille meurt.
Il arrive des fois que l'os se coupe.
Nous avons beaucoup de gorilles
infirmes dans la famille Kitonda,
il y a une femelle adulte
avec une jambe amputée.
Pour se libérer des pièges, les gorilles
s'amputent, ils se mutilent,
coupant le pied ou la main prisonnière.
Pour éviter l'infection, ils se soignent
avec les plantes médicinales de la forêt.
Depuis la guerre,
pas une famille n'a été épargnée.
Entre ceux tués par balles et ceux
qui n'ont pas survécu à leurs blessures,
beaucoup de gorilles sont morts.
Le gorille, c'est le plus proche
cousin de l'homme.
Alors quand un gorille meurt,
ça me cause du chagrin.
Quand le gorille meurt,
on fait un cimetière,
on l'enterre avec les honneurs.
Rugabo, le père de Kitonda,
le premier que Gapyra avait
rencontré lorsqu'il était enfant,
a été tué le 15 janvier 1995.
Au pied des volcans, Rumangabo,
le village de Gapyra.
C'est ici qu'ils ont enterré
les gorilles tombés au front.
Rugabo est là.
On a creusé sa tombe
et on l'a enterré ici.
Et sa femelle, on l'a enterré là,
à côté de lui.
- Ici ?
- Oui, on l'a mise là.
Et on sait qui les a tués ?
Pas vraiment.
On s'est réveillés un matin
et on les a trouvés morts.
Sans doute les Interhamwe.
Mais on n'a pas de preuves.
On n'a pas encore pu les identifier.
Gapyra est né dans ce village
il y a 42 ans.
Il y vit toujours avec les autres
gardes et leur famille.
De moins en moins de famille ou plutôt
de moins en moins de garde,
et de plus en plus de veuves.
- Comment ça va ?
- Ça va.
De quoi tu vis maintenant ?
Je m'en sors très difficilement.
Comment veux-tu que je fasse...
Et des indemnités, ils t'en donnent ?
Ils pensent à toi ?
Quand ils sont venus, ils ne m'ont
donné qu'une ration de nourriture.
Le bébé de celle-ci n'a pas connu son père
tombé au cours d'une patrouille, il y a un an.
Quatre enfants et depuis, elle a dû se
débrouiller avec l'équivalent de 6 francs.
Elle fait des haricots,
c'est ce que les gens mangent.
Dans la maison, ici, vous voyez la veuve,
son mari vient de mourir
il y a à peine une semaine.
Il est mort de malnutrition.
Gapyra est guère mieux loti
que les autres gardes.
Depuis 4 ans, il a dû fuir 2 fois sa maison
avec ses deux femmes et ses dix enfants.
Il parvient encore à nourrir
sa famille une fois par jour.
En deux ans, il a touché 150 francs.
Avant la guerre, il gagnait
600 francs par mois.
Nous sommes dans une période
très critique.
Peut-être que nous pourrions
avoir l'aumône,
que le Dieu Tout-Puissant,
pourra tomber du ciel pour nous aider.
Il y a aussi un autre problème,
Toutes les personnes qui ont peur
qu'on puisse leur voler leurs effets,
viennent les poser ici.
Toutes ces sacoches que vous voyez ici,
ça ne m'appartient pas.
Voilà par exemple des postes de radio,
qui ne m'appartiennent pas,
mais qui sont pour des tierces personnes.
Beaucoup de casseroles aussi
qui ne sont pas pour moi.
Cette mallette n'est pas pour moi.
Même ça, ce n'est pas pour moi.
Même des habits,
ce n'est pas pour moi.
Elle est venue cacher ses habits.
Uniquement les habits, c'est une femme.
Les Gapyra ont quand même
une richesse qui leur appartient,
un petit lopin de terre grâce auquel
mesdames Gapyra récoltent quelques haricots.
Ce matin, l'une d'entre elles va au marché
en vendre 5 kg pour gagner quelques billets,
de quoi s'acheter un peu de sel.
Toutes ces vendeuses sont des femmes
ou des filles de garde.
Certaines ont marché plus
d'une journée pour venir jusqu'ici,
une journée pour grappiller
quelques francs.
Un seul sachet de sel, ça coûte 250 000.
Il ne suffit même pas pour la semaine.
Les haricots,
on en consomme un kilo par jour.
En ne mangeant qu'un seul
repas par jour.
Comment voulez-vous qu'on s'en sorte avec
des enfants ? Il leur faut des bananes aussi.
On essaye de gagner un peu plus
en travaillant comme porteur,
ou en cassant des pierres.
Ils ont faim les enfants,
ils ont faim !
Et on doit tout faire à pied.
50 km aller, 50 km retour,
ça fait 100.
Avec tout sur la tête
pour ne gagner que 150 000.
150 000, vous ne vous rendez pas compte ?
Même pas assez pour un sachet de sel.
Dans les villages voisins,
on n'est pas mieux. Plutôt pire.
Bien sûr, tout le monde connaît Gapyra.
Bien sûr, tout le monde le salue.
Mais souvent on s'en prend à lui.
Ce serait bien qu'on puisse régler les litiges.
Entre le parc et la population.
Avant, on pouvait cultiver
autour du parc.
Maintenant, on nous l'interdit.
Avant, on pouvait aussi ramasser du bois.
Pourquoi on nous interdit tout ça ?
Qu'on autorise au moins
les gens à ramasser du bois,
qu'ils puissent reconstruire leur maison.
La population riveraine
du parc est pauvre.
à cause de la guerre
et de ses conséquences,
La population est sinistrée.
Il n'y a plus de vaches,
plus de chèvres, plus de poules.
La population n'a plus rien.
Elle n'a plus que ses yeux pour pleurer.
Alors, maintenant parler
de protection de la nature,
ça n'a plus aucun sens, je crains
que ça ne serve à rien.
On ne peut pas sacrifier la vie
des hommes pour celle des animaux.
Mais détruire la forêt,
ne provoque pas
que la mort des animaux.
Sans la forêt,
nous n'aurons plus de pluie.
Et sans pluie, plus de cultures.
Sans forêt, ce sera la faim et la mort.
Lorsque la nuit arrive sur Rumangabo
et que les femmes de Gapyra,
préparent le repas quotidien,
Gapyra n'a pas terminé sa journée.
La nuit, les gardes du parc
deviennent des cibles.
Ils sont obligés
de prendre des précautions.
- Vous êtes bien vigilants ?
- Oui, Monsieur.
Les interhamwe peuvent entrer ici ?
Non, ils n'entreront pas.
- Pourquoi ?
- Parce qu'on monte bien la garde.
On sait que les hommes de Gapyra
se serviront de leurs armes.
Alors la nuit, pour certaines,
le village devient un refuge.
- Vous venez toutes dormir ici ?
- Oui.
On a peur que les interhamwe
nous enlèvent.
Certaines sont encore prisonnières.
Et toi ? De quoi as-tu peur ?
Tu n'es qu'une enfant.
On a toutes peur des interhamwe.
C'est bon, allez-y.
Ces filles, on était très traumatisées.
Chaque jour, elles passent ici
vers 18 h 30-19 h,
et puis à 5 h 30 elles rentrent
dans leur village d'origine.
Il y a 6 filles
qui sont parties également,
ça faisait plus de 12 mois
qu'elles étaient en forêt,
elles viennent de rentrer avec six bébés.
Aujourd'hui, Gapyra a décidé de partir
tôt pour aller à la recherche de la famille
de Kitonda, le gorille.
Il ne nous a pas dit comment
il le savait, mais ce matin,
les gorilles doivent aller dans un endroit
où ils seront très exposés, plus vulnérables.
Toute lumière est interdite.
Ne pas devenir des cibles.
C'est avec une caméra infrarouge
que la marche a commencé.
Nos guetteurs sont partout
et en cas d'infiltration,
directement, ils nous avisent
en tirant une cartouche en l'air.
C'est quoi, le mot de passe ?
Le mot d'approche ?
Sekio.
Sekio !
C'est la nuit que les milices attaquent
les villages pour se ravitailler.
Au cours des six derniers mois,
sa patrouille a subi 3 accrochages.
Des heures et des heures de marche
en direction de l'un des volcans.
Chaque jour, il y a des accrochages
dans le secteur.
Nous suivons un sentier, rien ne permet
de savoir s'il a été emprunté par des hommes,
ou par des bêtes mais Gapyra
semble sûr de lui.
Vous voyez les restes d'aliments
qu'ils ont mangé.
C'est une plante arborescente.
Ils mangent la moelle.
Ils ne sont pas seulement végétariens,
mais ils mangent des fourmis,
et d'autres insectes
qu'on trouve dans les bois morts.
Par exemple, ici, ils ont mangé
les insectes qui étaient ici.
C'est un vernonia.
Et puis tout d'un coup... Des cris.
En fait, nous venons de tomber
en pleine scène de ménage.
Vous voyez, il vient de s'asseoir,
il n'y a pas de problème,
la femelle a refusé la copulation.
Quand la femelle refuse,
il y a une sorte de bagarre,
le mâle tape la femelle
et les autres crient.
Parfois, le silverback,
récupère la femelle et la met directement
en position accroupie,
la copulation se fait par derrière.
C'est presque la même chose
chez les humains.
C'est le cas par exemple des incestes.
Un gorille ne peut pas faire
la copulation avec sa maman,
tout comme l'humain ne peut pas
faire l'amour avec sa maman.
La scène de ménage oubliée, toute
la famille se met en marche tranquillement.
À l'évidence, Kitonda
ne se méfie pas de nous.
Il ne s'interpose pas entre ses enfants,
ses femelles et notre groupe.
La pente qui nous rapproche du sommet
devient un peu plus raide,
à quelques mètres, juste devant nous,
une femelle ferme la marche.
Kitonda nous a entrainés
jusqu'au sommet du volcan.
Devant nous, le trou du cratère.
Nous le suivons.
Bien sûr, Kitonda sait
que nous sommes derrière lui.
Il nous entraîne de plus en plus profond.
Jusqu'au fond.
Ici, effectivement, les gorilles
sont à découvert, très vulnérables.
Plus d'un quart de la population
des gorilles de montagne,
a été décimée depuis
le début de la guerre.
Il en resterait aujourd'hui,
à peine 500.
Moins de 30 familles.
Si Kitonda a amené sa famille ici,
probablement,
comme il avait vu son père le faire,
s'il a pris le risque de mettre
tous les siens en péril,
c'est parce qu'il y trouve
quelque chose de précieux.
Quelque chose qu'il sait ne pas
pouvoir trouver dans la forêt.
Les gorilles sont en train
de lécher le potassium,
qui est une sorte de sel.
Quand ils arrivent dans des endroits
pareils, ils ne le quittent jamais.
Ils m'ont appris la maîtrise,
je n'ai pas peur.
Ça m'a donné une expérience
unique pour moi.
Si demain, Gapyra
et ses gardes abandonnent,
il n'y aura plus de gorilles
sauf dans les zoos.